في الحادي والعشرين من مايو يحفظوا هذا
التاريخ جيدا 21 مايو هذا التاريخ هو
تاريخ مرحله جديده للسعوديه ولكن وين في
الفضاء في هذا اليوم سينطلق رائد الفضاء
السعوديان ريان برناوي وعلي القرني الى
محطه الفضاء الدوليه وطبعا ننوه هنا
مشاهدينا ان ريان برناوي هي اول سعوديه
واول عربيه مسلمه ايضا تقوم بهذه الرحله
انجاز رهيب الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء قالت
ان هذه الرحله تاتي ضمن برنامج المملكه
لرواد الفضاء الذي تم اطلاقه في الثاني
والعشرين من سبتمبر الماضي تتضمن اجراء
اربع عشره تجربه بحثيه علميه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات